well hello everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast the importance of
preoperative assessment and
post-operative care and surgical
procedures I am Marcel for edge until
then I'll be your moderator we have a
few important announcements to make
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive we encourage you to
ask questions as many questions as you
would like you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge this light window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or here
in this presentation and please click on
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
prominent through the green Q&A button
lower left I would like now to introduce
you to a special very special speaker
her name is belong at ISA Guzman hey
currently in Minneapolis but originally
from Bogota Colombia hey Pilar received
her DVN from the University of Lassa
Lassa a bogota colombia and an MS from
the University of Minnesota she is
currently the director of the
phenotyping corps in jackson hall and in
the cardiovascular and cancer research
building for the university of minnesota
i will now turn it over to dr. guzman
for her presentation
well I think of ourselves for that
presentation and yes he said I'm going
to be presenting the importance of
preoperative assessment most operation
care in during surgical procedures um
first I would talk a little bit about me
Marcel just told you I'm a DPM from the
university of south from Columbia I did
my master in science at the University
of Minnesota I work a long time as a lab
manager and research scientists in
hypertension lab research at the
University of Minnesota and at the
moment I am the director of the
phenotype in court for the Department of
integrative biology and physiology for
the University of Minnesota I'm just
going to give you guys an outline first
i'm going to give you an introduction
then i'm going to talk a little bit
about animal ordering also the
importance of how to receive an animal
and some talk to you about the drug that
you should be using during a surgical
procedure preparation for a surgical
procedure what do you need to have um
tips and things about doing a surgical
procedure I was surgical care which is
very important a lot of people kind of
forget about the do the surgery and they
don't they forget about this step a
little bit then we will go with the
conclusions I will give you some
reference of the things I done and then
finally we finish with questions so okay
so now we're going to solve the
introduction and alone all this time
they've been working here at the
University of Minnesota I was supposed
to end I started doing and surgical
procedures for the lab that I was
working and among some of the surgeries
that I did I had to perform surgeries I
had to create some surgical techniques i
did a myocardial infarcts to do Led
ligations and for this surgery I develop
a technique that i will open the chest
and a midline incision through the
afternoon because I didn't really like
opening the chest in the sides like most
people does it and I felt that I they
want to cut muscles and separate
because it was kind of very painful this
way i was able to do this and with this
i would do the LED ligation i also did
connect estella contacted me through
here or placing and flow probes to
determine cardiac output um my other
surgeries idea is done connectome is in
mesenteric and many other gamblers in
the abdomen also I've done renal
denervation or recording and some of the
implants that are used were like slow
probes that I look like as I mention you
in the ascending aorta on the renal
artery on the mesenteric re just to
measure arterial flow probe using the
transonic flow meters for this as well I
use the transmitter from dsi i use it
for rats and mice this is really nice
because you will be able to measure
arterial pressure and heart rate for 24
hours every three minutes as long as the
battery life of da of the transmitter
for the Reds a battery life is like
around three months that transmitters
for the mice is like a month and a half
so that's a nice thing to have when
you're doing some kind of studies of
cardiovascular studies also I've in
place as Moloch pumps and just to
deliver any kind of drug anything that
you want through a sub-q that's
important also you can use all these
osmotic pumped for Frank brain infusions
I did a study bring this and brain
infusion kids and third ventricle
implant and giving them Vince Emil to
block sodium channels for the study that
we did for hypertension there's also
pumps there's a new pump the name is I
pressure pump this apprecia palm is
really nice as you can program this pump
in the computer you can refill it even
though when is in the animal and through
the skin in through here this kind of
the punch here you can refill more
solution you can explain it from one
animal in if you weigh like explaining
take two days click while you clean it
in this
infected again is sterilizing you can
put it in another enemy it's very
accurate is very nice the only thing is
this I pre-show pump cause like well
between four to five hundred dollars
well this one's cause between twenty
dollars to forty dollars each depends on
what you need and you can choose
whatever whatever study we need or if
you need or you can choose either one i
also have used like a small ventilators
this is a rare ventilator or a mouse
ventilator but in this case is a
ventilator using trach tube that I made
to intubate rats or mice for open chest
surgery and if needed so now let's take
a little bit about the animal order how
to other animals this is very important
is the first part of everything do you
need there's many many rodent suppliers
then you can choose and I'm just putting
a sample here Charles River or having
laboratory's you can use but the
important thing of this is to always
make sure that you order when you decide
which animal you always should order
your animals at the same place at the
same supplier and sometimes it should
supplier have different cds or different
place so always make sure that your over
in your ass or your animals from the
same supplier and their supply from the
same location in order for you not to
have any inconvenience also determine
what type of animal you need you need a
round you need amount in what type of
RADS there's many many types of rats um
exam an example I do some down sensitive
Brad from Norway's break down the Reds
and in mice well there's all the
transgenic that you can help so just
make sure they always consistent in the
autumn of the end the receiving the
animals is very important receiving the
animal you have to remember that the
animals arrive in cardboard boxes they
have just a gel as food but sometimes
this transfer takes between for two or
four days or sometimes a week or if its
overseas one more so you have to make
sure that at the moment on arrival you
will have a clear cage with clean water
and fresh food
in a fresh clean nice on th to put them
on also you have to make sure that the
cages label with the birthday with all
the information comes from the supplier
and it's very very important that at the
moment of the arrival to avoid any
stress showing in your study you have to
leave like at least a week give the
animals at least a week so they are
recovered from the stress of the our
transportation otherwise if you some
people notice that they arrive and the
animals all right the next day they
start doing surgeries all the stress of
a week is going to be showing in your
data and then you're not going to be
able to make sense of it so always make
the animal one would make sure that the
animals are look healthy it's very
important if the animals are not healthy
just report it to the supplier they
should be able to give you another set
because is you don't want that in your
in your study and it's very very
important because you know that and
rodents are social they're always in
groups but sometimes in most of the time
when we do studies they're going to be
in individual cages so give them some
enrichment the mice get something like
this the radicand is put to paper towels
they cannot play with it and they have
something to do this so that's very
important in that decrease your stress
now let me talk a little bit about the
drug that you should use in a surgical
procedure so first a gas station gas
anesthesia is made is minimized and its
credit vital and so because of this
there's always going to be a depression
and cardiovascular system in our in the
land so all you have to just remember
that so some of the drugs like eater is
a slow response it's toxic to the liver
but you will have to a premedicate with
a with anticholinergics and reduce the
excess or respiratory secretions the
induction and recovery is a little rough
and you must be if you're going to use
it you go you have to go with a
coordinating with the guidelines using
them that ether so I mean if you need to
use it okay but you remember there is
like service performance has always on
not about
about it we talk Celine is a slow to
respond is toxic to the kidneys and as
well oh like as I told you depressor
respiration in cardiovascular system the
same with Hal attorneys motor response
and but is toxic to the kidney into the
labor and well the process
cardiovascular and pulmonary system now
there is two like that in so foreign and
the ISO flooring i suppress the one that
I like the most and I use most but both
of them are respond fast there's no
toxicity in both the process the
cardiovascular and respiratory system so
just so you guys have an account which
and Anastasia you will be using the
injector one is tisha injector decision
are dreaming normally a metallized in
the liver and excreted by the kidneys
the rotifer ministration can be
intramuscular and secure interpreter
many many ways to inject it and local
anesthesia could be servicing normal
kind anyone say they didn't like a
process mean less upon on any of the
ones you want and I'm going to talk a
little bit of the perfect works I use
the carpet unix a lot especially in the
open chest surgery and I will tell you
why so the pentobarbital is the longest
action of the Barbie tricks the
pentobarbital is short acting of the oxy
barbiturates and there's some advantage
of this one's the great thing is you can
put an interpreter Nellie and because
holder the animal goose is conscious
very fast in which is good and also in
the Anastasia a last longer like 45 to
120 minutes the good thing about this if
you do it next time for that open chest
surgery um you know that you're going to
be open your chest you have to restore
the negative pressure orga and Torres so
when I start using it long time ago with
the chaos the animals will wake up in
that kind of difficult they don't know
how to breathe because they think they
have to learn so I decided to go to the
Barbie tricks so the good thing about
this is there as soon as I finish the
surgery like in 30 minutes or something
I let them connected into the ventilator
and I let them wake up and when they are
I'm getting out of the resonator I
disconnected from the and from the trach
tube and let them awhile and then take
out the trade tube this will allow the
animal to slowly slowly kind of learn
again how to bring in we store them
they're fresher and then when they wake
up they'll just come down to not stress
and that's a good thing however there
are some disadvantage with the BBQ ribs
the BBQ ribs are concealed narcotics in
there for door control substance so you
have to deal with all the stuff of
control sucks and you have to write down
everything you do how many a menial you
get to the animal if you mix it if you
want anything that's the thing about the
control system but even though with this
a disadvantage is the power ensign
anesthetic most used in oratory animals
and overall its release is just an
injection so that's the sum that's a
good thing now there's also drug
combination is very normal to mix
anesthetic or not I mean analgesic does
that's fine but you have to make sure
that when you're mixing Cremeans you
know anyone during expiration day of
this mixture is 30 days you should not
use it 30 days after so it's very
important in in the bottle wherever you
mixin it right down the day that you are
you made it in the day is going to
expire to make sure so you're giving
something good to the enemy also the
analgesic like be premiering normally
for mice you have to tell you this so
make remember the 30 days of spiration
also remember to if you see and make
sure their shows and the precipitation
change the color the transference is not
right it doesn't look right discharge
don't use it because maybe you're not
going to be able to get me put your
animal down and have your animal input a
good conditions for improper for surgery
now analgesics so I'm going to do
several and just injectable God for
North en route to meet your phone on
they're great but you have to inject
them twice a day they're very important
and injectables which is nice but if
you're doing a simple soldier that just
put in a farm
or something really simple I don't
recommend this I've seen along my career
that we do pronoun one is something
really not very invasive or something
what happened is the animal gets
phenomenal and they start an abiding in
your limbs and in the wound in the next
that you come and everything is open and
it's not right so in that case I will
choose kiddo preferred anyone of this
but I like the kiddo program format and
rice mice and rights rats which is a
great one and what I like about this are
drunk is that you have to inject the
only one time only one time so you're
gonna have to handle the animal the
handle after the animal after a surgery
you don't they don't want to be touched
so the less you touch them the better
but in also and injectables is very
important then I just want to say it
well now maybe I will say it again later
to just reinforce idea is it after you
do surgery the animals um normally the
next day of the surgery the animals are
not going to drink anything you know the
roegans are nocturnal they are active in
at night and the drink and eat at night
so I always make sure and I always like
to give an injectable the next day of
the surgery to make sure that the animal
is well controlled the plane of the
animal is well control and then you can
just give them oils the orrans are very
good and ibuprofen is very nice for
rodents or anyone in the water for three
days but always make sure that you
measure and you put the mixture in the
water and you measure that water bottle
and the next day after the other so in
the surgery waited by the bottom what
about make sure that they're really
drinking and if they're not drinking
just go ahead and put another injectable
because they're so they're comfortable
let's talk about antibiotics imran's
gentamicin is a grade on Tobias is in a
moon spectrum um it attacks a lot of run
negative in one positive which is great
but it is scientifically you should only
use one time is that if you use it
several times in the animal like for the
a recovery period is a toxic to the
kidneys so you don't want that it's very
good for the moment in the soldiery barn
not for the recovery
time you can use some excessively you
can use may enter frog saline soon for
mice you can use the inner folks in
order to metro pain sulfate it's fine
now let's talk about prepare for
surgical procedure but it's important
for technical procedures now you will
have your suture and your surgical
package in this surgical package you
should have your campus your to buy gas
2 x 24 x 4 q-tip sutures or anything
else that you might need during the
surgery that you need also your surgical
instrument you should make the surgical
instrument that you need in a surgical
package I have a small autoplay and and
so I like to use it I put everything
during the day of the surgery it's ok to
do it the day before but it is always
better if you just do it the same day
make sure that is completely clean so
what I do is I come in the morning I put
my package that I have them ready put
them in autoplay and while i'm setting
up all the silikal place they're being
autoclave and they're ready to go
exactly when i'm done you can also use
psychics class to disinfect to sterilize
your instruments sitex a solution that
is very slow acting so if you're going
to use psychics to Sir lies your
instruments make sure you put the
instruments to die before the surgery
and you need at least 12 hours prior to
the surgery for these instruments to be
completely realized with sightings and
then when you take them out make sure
you rinse them with the still water do
not use saving the sailing I noticed
when you do saline arm is kind of it's
not good for the animals or say this to
water is great it's great to just clean
the instruments you can also use tools
muchos if you want you can use exam make
sure you have examined in surgical and
glanced in your surgical come in here
what I want to make sure is we always
have to use something to cover right
here here is what is more introduce more
infection so out of those make sure you
have something to cover your hair now
I'm going to talk about how to prepare
the surgical area here you know I'm have
stainless steel but not you really don't
have to if you don't have it that's fine
what it's much important is that put
plays like a blue pants or something
something clean on top of the table and
about the area you're going to have and
then on top of that clean you're going
to put your surgical sterile surgical
package if you notice here's my heating
pad and I got like a acrylic piece that
we can up and glue something so we have
like an envelope to put underneath is a
heating pad that's very important
because you can also disinfectants you
can put alcohol or something in this
infect the whole area now now I have
this all my area is my my campaign
everything is open completely sterile
this here everything is sterile and
ready to go no I have your my light make
sure you have light is very important
that the surgeon is comfortable because
if you're comfortable the animal is
going to do fine you have your sharpies
you have your name and to put down and
move down here this is the you don't
need this fancy I mean something to suck
the the anesthesia when you win when you
have the nose cone and you're using the
animal has a nose cone in is using yes
so make sure that some of that gas it
could be escaping from that nose cone
with their at their gas is taken out of
you in New not reading it because then
is not good you're going to have
headaches and stuff is not very good now
the preparation area should be
designated different from the surgical
area sometimes I see ah they use they
just prepare the animal right beside the
circular II that's not good because
you're going to have hair all over and
you're going to affect your store area
now um sorry I'm just going to go back a
little bit because i want to show you so
here i have my razor blade i have the
iodine alcohol to x 24 x for gas and
q-tips and I came back because of this
is very important you have a balance
it's very important to me
to weigh the rat the day of the story
you see a lot of people i don't need
upper body weight so for my study so i'm
not going to win my enemy this is very
important because it's the clue is going
to give you after the three days of
recovery for the enemy if they're
recovering or not sometimes and as i
could sign a few if you can help the
animal it will be ready to to help the
enemy in case something happens now if
you're using the Anastasia machine and
isoprene always make sure that you have
good levels of gas in the machine for
the surgery as well as make sure that
your oxygen tank is full or is good
enough volume and I'm telling you this
because sometimes it happens if you
don't have enough you out well you will
you animal will die because then you can
knock out by the time you change so some
of this wouldn't happen so I just want
to make sure that this is remember so
now you put the animal in a gas chamber
and you see the chamber so when you have
it here make sure that you have
everything you need ready for the enemy
now shaving the mice I always use nair
you can also choose shape in a razor
blades but I don't like it because their
skin is so thin just a little bit of
Nair you put it in the area of the
surgery and then with a tool a tool with
a little bit of sailing I'll just clean
it and you have a beautiful area clean
populating for your hair you're ready to
start like for rats you can use a razor
blade and what i like is i just shave
everything the area that I need in you
see here is a little vacuum a wireless
cordless vacuum and then with that what
I do is I always Backman every hair and
you see here there's no hair all over
and that's what I want to run any hair
because the hair is going to be the
focus of the infection and in my surgery
so now in the nail can be used on rats
like here I'm just putting a little bit
of an air and you have to make sure that
the nair is only for 20 to 30 seconds
don't need it longer it's going to
affect the skin of the animal soul you
just put a little bit and then you see
that here is very nice if you go
to do an ultrasound or an open chest
surgery or something this is perfect you
can also do it here if you're going to
do an ultrasound for the kidney the
liver already part is perfect for rent
now I'm going to show you how not to
shave somebody gave me these pictures in
a say well thank you but if you can see
there's a lot of hair a lot of hair
around here in what happened is when you
finish the surgery I don't know if you
can see there's little hairs here and
then look at all this hair all this hair
can come into an infection and sometimes
people ask me I shave it everything in
why my man who is affected in a show
them look all the hair that you guys
have that can lead to an infection and
on top of the other animals in a bedding
type in all the bedding can become so
everything adds up and so you want to
make sure that you shaving correctly I'm
to avoid infections now this in fact ins
we can use novice on or I'm iodine in
the animal here in this moment I use
iodine in here because there's no hair
the chorus mass is intense is here but
it's important when you use iodine or
one of this use alcohol in a then clean
all the surface you don't want to leave
all the residual iodine in the reason is
because iodine dries the skin and the
next day after the surgery is very
uncomfortable for the animals in the
start kind of itching and they start
biting them selves when you come in one
they opened our rooms and they start
biting your toes so you don't want that
so make sure that you remove that iodine
from the animal in all this area's then
clean so everything is serving ready for
sleeping now let me talk to you about a
little bit of the doing the surgical
procedures what you will need to do so
first prior to start the surgery you
have to have your anesthesia if you want
to use Nembutal if you're going to use
and I'm suffering again remember
induction is four to five percent in
Maine is two percent if you're going to
use some mixture of drugs remember
always use atropine because it will
reduce the situation from the
respiratory system
new antibiotic of choice gentamicin I
really like using this one and Philip
Roth on your analgesic that's very
important now there is important to have
a checklist during the surgery so you
have to make sure that the heating pad
is on the anesthesia any type of
anesthesia normally reduces the
temperature of the body of the animal so
you always have to have a heating pad
make sure that the devil distinction
animals are correct are done so you
pinch the toes or you Pinkston it
entails or something make sure that the
animal is fun you also make sure that
they have a good heart rate for me is
really easy i always have a transmitter
that I can hear the heart but maybe not
everybody has a transmitter so make sure
that the animals breathing right is not
if the breathing is too slow is because
the dummy cs2 dead so if you're using
gas you because we move a little bit the
nose cone and lower and lower the
percentage of anesthesia and bring it
back and make sure that the rate
respiration rate is normal the same
thing you have to look for the color of
the skin the color skin should always be
pink if it becomes a little wider is
because the anesthesia that is too much
so make sure that you do the same thing
remove as Dom the cone the nose cone and
over angle beta dumb the anesthesia now
for injectibles is a little bit more
different so for injectable you have to
make sure that you wait completely very
well of the animal and can't make the
calculation repeated check it out check
it and make sure that you giving the
exact amount of anesthesia because if
something like this happen is there are
some ways that you can get the animal
order but is going to be more difficult
to get this segment assessment should be
done during the surgery every 10 to 15
minutes so normally as that we are alone
we're not we don't have like in our
medical doctors they have like several
people helping them but in our case
we're just there so may get the habit of
doing your surgery in front of it
looking at the end
the animal so it's fun it's very
important to them rodents do not close
your eyes with the surgery so if you put
in I element in the eyes of the rat or
the mouth it's very good you don't want
to lose their eyes because they never
are going to be able to eat or drink and
then it's not going to be able to animal
for any study I have here a surgical
chart that I have for my own studies I
have is this is very important for you
you have a looking right here the
project name of the project the oldest
type of surgery you're going to be doing
in this animal the idea of the animal
the body weight of the animal this is
very important because it's zero control
for the three days after the story of
the control period to make sure that the
animal is gaining weight again always
after any surgery the animal is going to
lose weight so you want to make sure
that animal is gaining weight and out
then is is recovering you have your
anesthesia here either one the ones
you're going to use atropine gentamicin
and do you just check mark making sure
that you remember what to do the heating
pad make sure there's always on make
sure that the animal has enough
anesthesia Deb and it's ready to go the
time for the surgery finish in time with
surgery ends and when it started in it
so this is very important because
sometimes if we take too long in the
surgery we can know what happened or
something so it's very important in here
this is to remind you that every 10 to
15 minutes you just have to make sure
that they haven't runs fine then you
analgesic at the time the animal is
awake and here you can put any notes or
anything about the surgery and these for
me this is very helpful because when I
do surgeries I I mean in study and study
my studies are 100 200 animals and I'm
not going to remember every single end
but if I see an outlier in my study I
always want to go back to the chart
doing the surgery and see if something
happened in a surgery that can help me
understand and sometimes it does now for
abdominal surgical procedures just when
you have an animal you doing midline
incision you put on campus make sure
that you cover it and if you want to
take that song which is
fine make sure you have a 4 by 400 new
temples take the guts out and with
saline which will have saline you cover
with other four by four and you have to
make sure that always the gods are moist
you don't want the guts to shut down
because if you don't do that you're
going to put them back into the animal
and maybe the animals not going to make
it the next day or two or three days
after so always make sure that the gods
are completely moist and here you have a
space you move everything around here's
the kidney you can if you're going to
remove a kidney if you're going to do we
know the innovation or anything you just
set up this area for you to do soldiers
now this is my sport procedure that I do
for the heart I do through right through
the ester mom and I make the cut and I
can open the heart I got tore up Scotty
and then I can see nicely here the heart
here's the LED I can negate the LED here
I can do not get an estimate on your
neck to be here in before me underneath
here or i can just put here right here
the flow pro in ascending aorta this is
another one i didn't put any compass
because i wanted you guys to see very
well the things now let's go and talk
about a surgical care which is very
important and sometimes people forget
about that you have to keep taking care
of the enemy make sure that you have a
heating pad then is turn on and then
your animal is going to be there in the
heating pad at least an hour after they
they wake up and recover you want to
have them close to you in close to the
owner so if something happens you can
help them with anything here so this is
very important and their support
surgical care for three days so make
sure that you give them the energetics
could be duper legs or kiddo profane or
profane whatever is your choice in
antibiotics they could be an accessory
in or in fluoxetine whatever in whatever
is your choice I have a chart here i'm
going to show you this chart for the
recovery time I have three days three
days the same way and each day i have a
check mark for morning and afternoon
I have an area for analgesic an area for
antibiotics making sure that the animals
eating and drinking and the pain
assessment if they look fine if their
hair is normal not frizzy making sure
the down is that is because the animal
is in pain and you can have here
something to write down information that
you need now make sure that during the
surgery and after the free recovery time
that animal looks healthy and nice and
here i always use this kind of am white
kind of tau is reinforce what towel and
what I like about that is right after
the surgery I will put the animal right
there they recover and at least I have a
window like four to five hours that the
animal is going to stay there and it's
not going to be infecting a double so I
really like that and it's very nice and
also the next day is kind of enrichment
that you have is the next day you see
it'll mess messed up and everything is
fine it's perfect because that means
that the animal is active and it's great
is in is doing fine normally when I do
with surgery the next day the animals
drinking and it's very active it's
really nice here this is one of the
charts that I did long time ago for open
chest surgery but i'm just going to show
you all i want you guys to concentrate
on this area i have a transmitter can
measure heart rate and after pressure
and I place a card airflow probe in the
ascending aorta for Connecticut so this
is the day of the surgery and if you
know only about a week after seven to
eight days the animals are recovering
your circadian rhythm yeah this is very
important to know that's why in day ten
I decided always I decided for this kind
of surgeries I decide to start any any
study or any treatment that I have the
reason that you don't want to do any
study in this period and a lot of people
just to surgery in the next day you're
doing whatever study is because all this
is going to be stressed so if you do
anything your day is going to be look
funny and weird and strange like why
doesn't look normal it's because it's in
this period of stress so make sure they
never use it otherwise is new data is
not going to make sense now if you're
going to collect
just a simple surgery like a sub to me
pop or something well you can just get
them three to four days and then you can
start something so that's going to be
funny now the animals are going into the
housing area and you'll find they're
supposed to be labeled everything and
look at them and you're fine now to
finish and I have some conclusions and
this is very important it's very
important to be consistent while you're
ordering animals um make sure you're
giving the animals at least a week to
recover and this is very very important
choose correctly the additional just in
antibiotics according with your study
according with what you're going to be
doing remember shaving correctly we
don't work in sections and it's
important to disinfect the surgical area
of the enemy and where you're going to
between surgeries during the surgical
period check the animal vitals all the
time every 10 to 15 minutes making a
habit of checking the enemies the
recovery time is important is all the
process so you have to make sure that
during those three days of recovery
you're checking constantly the animal
making sure goodnight fun and remember
the success of your study will depend on
how well you can you care for your
animals during the whole process so now
I'm going to give you some rappin that
you later can check if you want this is
all the studies that I've done some of
them that I've been doing for many many
pies and you can check them later if you
want so now I think we're ready for
questions and thank you for everybody to
listen to me I hope it was helpful for
everybody and anything people would like
to to ask me i'm ready now thank you
okay well thank you for that informative
presentation belong and before we get
started on the question and answer
session i would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them and the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window well
answer will try to answer as many
questions as we can and our first
question is let's see first question is
for from Madeline Stevens from ubc is
there a reason you use ketoprofen over
meloxicam hi Marilyn no it really is not
you can use I just my experiences your
protein is really easy to use and is
really nice so you can use if you have
worked with that one and it works fine
for you is fun there's no reason is and
why to choose one over the other and we
just put in some samples hope that
respond you're okay the next question
comes from Sarah Williamson from bi VI
what do you recommend is an injectable
anesthetic for rabbits you know I don't
have a lot of experience with rats ah
but the people that have work with
rabbits tell me that I'm most the same
thing that you can get two rollers you
can get to grab it but i'm not i'm not
sure i can give you that give you that
information on yeah sorry thanks
next one is from Madeline Madeline
Stevens from UBC why do you you why do
you not use saline rinse instruments I
missed your answer hi Medellin oh really
this something personal I feel that if
you put so much salt or something um you
can do it but I kind of like more than
stillwater it's turtle distilled water
is kind of more fresh I feel that I'm
not adding anything to the animal no
sodium or anything that could irritate
even though you can just put it in if
you don't have anything else it's just I
think it's more of a personal choice and
I see in alone all this year that when I
do that when I used to do that now i
doona autoplay but when i used to do
that before we didn't have an autoclave
um I noticed it was kind of better when
I was in the renal denervation tour when
i was doing moving kidney or anything
into the abdomen specially sometimes i
will see some irritation so I decided
one day okay I'm just going to use the
steel water and I didn't see that but I
mean everybody has your own experience
you can yeah you can do that thank you
the next question comes from Valerie
Schrader from University University of
Notre Dame are there any inhalation and
aesthetics other than sevoflurane and
isoflurane that are available in the US
halothane a metal thing are not
available well maybe maybe they are but
really was most everybody uses it is I
so chlorine or there's many other ones
maybe depends on whatever you're going
to be doing like I know in here mr.
several some that maybe do not depress
the respiratory system in the
cardiovascular system but most everybody
is very common to use it but um it's a
matter of looking with the
in your area what you have so but anyway
even anyway if you mean using gas is
very safe it's safer in either one you
use not not using the ether the most or
kind of all type of gases I really
wouldn't recommend unless you need to do
it but yeah you can use anyone thanks
well that appears to be all our
questions so I think we can wrap it up
at this point and I want to thank the
audience for their interesting questions
or participation in today's event and
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2015
you won't receive an email from lab
looks alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time and thank
you very much everybody